what does it take to put together the
perfect team it takes the perfect one
dad but how do you write the perfect one
tab most of us take out ad in the
newspaper and Craigslist and we say what
we're looking for an account executive
or personal assistant something like
that and we get inundated with responses
but that doesn't guarantee that the
people that we're going to hire are
great fits because what makes a great
team are people who believe what you
believe if somebody believes what you
believe they're going to work for you
with blood and sweat and tears if they
don't believe what you believe
they work for your money the example I
love to use is of Ernest Shackleton
Shackleton was a turn-of-the-century
English explorer and what makes him
famous is that he and his team were
stranded in the Antarctic ice for 22
months but what makes Shackleton
expedition famous is that no one died no
one died after 22 months being stranded
on the ice this was not lucky Shackleton
hired the perfect team
and just like us he took out an ad in
the newspaper he took out an ad in the
London Times now it didn't say what he
needed
it didn't say men needed for expedition
must have five years experience and know
how to hoist the mainsail
that's not what he said and think about
how we write one tides account executive
needed minimum five years experience
must have a working knowledge of
Microsoft Office and we get inundated
with responses what Shackleton's ad said
was something different he was brutally
honest about what the conditions were
like to work aboard his ship and on this
expedition and his ad in the London
Times went like this men needed for
hazardous journey long hours
bitter cold dark nights survival
doubtful if success Honor guaranteed the
only people who were applied for the job
were people who loved insurmountable
odds the only people who apply for the
job were people who read that ad and
went cool and that's why Shackleton and
his crew survived on the ice for 22
months he hired people who were great
fits now when we take out ads or when
we're interviewing people
we sometimes butter up what the job is
going to be like we're not brutal
honest if your office is chaotic tell
people that it's that it's chaotic if
you're in office environment is one
where everybody works late say that in
your ads say that in your interview
because if you don't you're going to
hire people who fall in love with the
job that you're selling but not the job
that they get be brutally brutally
honest what it's like to work for you
and what you believe and you'll find it
amazing the kinds of people you can
recruit for your team I did this
recently when I hired somebody to join
my team and if you look below you can
see the exact one tad that I use to find
somebody on Craigslist
I wasn't inundated with responses
because I said exactly what I believed
and I was brutally honest about what it
was like to work for me the amazing
thing was I found the perfect person in
just four days somebody who believes
what I believe so go ahead uses the
template and see how well you do and
don't forget find somebody who believes
what you believe not just who does what
you need them to do